at a distance you could mistake hi-rez
Studios game paladin's for overwatch
there are a few similar character
designs and abilities in both games
leading some internet commenters to call
paladins a clone high res CEO Todd
Harris addressed these accusations in a
lengthy reddit post and in an interview
with IGN while he admits paladin's
borrowed some mechanics like kill cams
and lag compensation he fully denies the
game being a ripoff he responded while
overwatch is a fine game it was not the
inspiration for paladins for the hero
shooter genre the game that deserves the
most credit is Team Fortress 2 we
released a tf2 inspired class-based
shooter called Global Agenda way back in
2010 paladins was conceived as a fantasy
version of global agenda and of the
approximately 85 combat abilities
currently in paladins the vast majority
are from the game we made 10 years ago
Paris's reddit post contains plenty of
links to paladins footage that predates
overwatch in the end this whole debacle
seems like a classic case of parallel
thought of course if you want to avoid
the issue altogether
you could always play high reza's
mythological mobis might instead and to
keep up with all the upcoming projects
from both high-res and blizzard you're
already in the right place